we have a couple of special guests with
us in st. Louis we have former world
champion Garry Kasparov who will be
playing against Nigel short now they had
already played a match long long time
ago for the World Championship or at
least the PCA World Championship and
Kasparov won that match so this is kind
of a rematch of a very long time ago
match back in the early 90s so Kasparov
a former world champion but Nigel short
also one of the strongest players of
this time all right
so in honor of one of the strongest
British people to have ever played the
game of chess Nigel short I'm gonna show
you probably what's considered to be the
first strongest player from England Sir
Joseph Henry Blackburn now when we talk
about black born we're talking about all
chess I mean old chess this guy was
influenced by Morphy and I'm not talking
up I'm not talking about this guy you
know like us like we saw more if he's
games and we were like wow I want to be
like more if you know I'm talking I'm
saying that this guy actually saw more
if you play they never actually they
never actually met in a match but but
Blackburn did see more if you play in
some of his simultaneous exhibitions in
Europe and he was very influenced by
more freestyle and he really wanted to
play like Morphy so we're talking about
Blackburn really old-school Blackburn he
died at the age of 82 in 1924 so this
we're talking about a really long time
ago I mean max you wasn't world champion
a lurking wasn't thinking about it you
know world war 2 nobody you in like
stein it said so yeah well that's that's
what we're talking about we're talking
about Steinitz we're talking about
chigorin we're talking about zuker
thought we're talking about Terra but
those are the people that were the
contemporaries of blackboard
who played chess at a relatively
advanced age he is one of his brilliant
brilliant games was against aron
nimzowitsch and he played this in 1914
at the tender age of 72 so the guy was a
professional chess player he was always
playing just he always competed in
tournaments but he was even better known
as a simultaneous exhibition ER he was
famous for like playing hundreds of
people in simultaneous exhibitions and
just crushing and crushing and playing
this brilliant combinations now
Blackburn never had any real chances at
the World Championship title he was
never really that strong he was never
strong as chigorin he was never
strongest Steinitz and he was never
strong a super dork
but he always won against them in some
in once in a while he always had really
good games and we're gonna see a couple
of them now Blackburn had a nickname
anybody know the nickname of Blackburn
he was the Black Death he was the Black
Death of chess and he was named such
after the Vienna tournament of 1973
because in 1973 I had this like habit of
saying nineteen something on 1873 and
here he just crushed everybody pretty
much just destroyed the competition so
we're gonna take a look at a couple of
games and now we gotta remember
Blackburn is one of the classics okay
this guy they don't play good chess he
played romantic jazz he played killer
chess so sonic has combinations were not
exactly sound but who cares
we're gonna take a look at one of his
games that were considered like pretty
cool and he's black in this moment so
he's gonna live up to his expectations
is the black that he for ePHI d4 takes
takes now this is 1892 alright so the
concept of the night of Sicilian okay
neither hasn't even been born yet so we
were way way behind theory then you know
they just kind of played whatever
Blackburn was known to play very strange
things as both black and white including
such things that starting them the games
with like d3
or even efore if ePHI Bishop e2 you know
he was known to do stuff that didn't
really make sense but who cares because
he was Blackburn so d4 he p4 takes and
then we got this kind of normal setup
with the move to g6 nowadays T
recommends Knight f6 but who cares g6
Bishop d2 Bishop g7 Knight c3 Knight g7
so both sides just kind of cohesively
trying to bring their pieces into the
game why it's gonna Castle queenside
because that's where she's liberated the
most amount of space black is gonna
Castle kingside
so in the true style of the old classics
we're gonna have a match between wits
and see who is going to attack first
castles castles and f4 which is already
considered to be a little bit of a
mistake even though it looks like a
pretty natural move the reason this was
considered a mistake is that it doesn't
do much for White's development and it's
just a little bit too slow he needed to
hurry it up a little bit and play Bishop
c4 also because he needs to take control
over a squared d5
even though Blackburn was known as an
attacking genius and a person whose
combinations were not exactly always
sound he did have a lot of strong
positional concepts like most great
attackers and we were talking about this
last week most great attackers at some
point had really strong positional
understanding now of course this is for
the date this is for you know he had a
very strong position understanding for
1892 this is back when steinitz was
still coming up with his ideas and
principles of chess-like
initiative and attack and all these
things that we know we're now using our
common lingo
we're not exactly even you know words at
the moment to describe things in chess
so f for d5 and the central break is
actually quite powerful the idea is not
so much to hello to take immediately
back on d5 but it's more the idea that
after pawn takes d5 black board is just
not going to care
and he's gonna go boom night before so
the idea here is that after night before
the pawn on d5 has attacked yet again
but there's another important idea and
that is that after Bishop c4 Bishop f5
was played putting pressure on this pawn
right here on c2 so blood white is being
forced back by every move defending
every single one of his pieces of course
you cannot allow such an important point
to disappear I mean it's in front of
your king
so Bishop b3 was played and now only now
black both took the time to regain his
pawn 90 takes d5 Knight takes d5 Knight
takes d5 now Queen f3 which was a little
mistake and here black born with his
powerful bishops and he was known for
his powerful bishops use the diagonal to
great effect the first move Queen f6
boom threatening checkmate on b2 right
so the knight on d5 there's no time to
take it you must defend from the
checkmate threat so BAM c3 blocking out
my pieces so black man one night B for
giving up the knight yet again if the
pawn takes again Queen takes B -
checkmate
now the problem is that there's also a
93 check after the King goes to one of
c2 or b1 it falls under the influence of
the bishop so I will be able to retreat
the night probably to e5 and then take
the Queen everybody follow more or less
so the threat here is that after for
example I go something whatever I go
check now the King has to move here here
right and it's in the influence of this
Bishop so I go 95 check check because of
the bishop now the King let's say it
moves and I have to I can take the Queen
so for this reason colburn whoever that
is played Bishop c4 defending the d3
square
and then BAM a bolt from the blue and
this was a Blackburn was famous for and
this is back when they showered the
boards with gold when they saw a
brilliant combination some pretty
sacrifices Queen a6
if Bishop takes a six-night takes a to
checkmate a distraction sacrifice the
bishop is under attack
so here colburn tried to survive by
playing g4 hoping that if I take away
this bishop I can only survive for
example after Queen takes e4 pawn takes
f5 it's true that White's much worse
after Knight takes a - I want a pawn and
his your Kings not feeling too safe but
nothing concrete yes yeah I mean you're
still alive but Blackburn just didn't
care
Queen takes a to putting the Queen in
pre yet again because if Bishop takes a
to the same checkmate Knight takes a -
and White has no time to play pawn takes
f5 because of the move Queen a1 so here
Colburn tried to play the move Bishop e3
Bishop e3 trying to save himself you
know if check I can maybe I don't know
go king d2 on Queen takes b2 and go back
and survive and defend and hope and beg
but Blackman was not one for mercy the
issue of c3 leaving the Queen hanging
yet again but because the bishop is now
covering d2 this is still checkmate if
the bishop is taken Queen c2 is made if
this Bishop is taken and the bishop is
still defending this so I can go Queen
takes b2 or Queen erryone checkmate and
there's just nothing to do you cannot
defend against both Queen takes b2 and
Queen a 1 so here Colborne resigned
there's a good old style of the
romantics trying to sacrifice every
piece to get to the king total 18 moves
yeah
yes it was very influenced by morphe
actually so black man was considered to
be the strongest British player for a
very very long time actually until you
know relative modern history he was he
grew up in the Manchester chess club or
at least his chest carrier did and he
dominated the field for many many years
it was difficult for a lot of players to
play against him because he was so
aggressive and even though most of his
things don't necessarily work they were
still difficult to deal with so we're
gonna take a couple of examples of his
play this is him against the man this is
world champion William Stein it before
he was world champion so this was
actually 1907 I see again you know like
I always want to say nineteen something
this is London 1883 this is before
William Stein it's moved to America will
Stein it's moved to America because he
couldn't find a job in London England
and he decided to move to America for a
better future in America he challenged
suger toured for the match in the World
Championship and it played and famously
in New York st. Louis and New Orleans
but this is before that match happened
and before steinitz moved out of England
so he was in Austria he was born in
Austria he lived a while in England and
then he moved to America so this is back
before then Joseph herring Blackburn is
white against William Stein it's before
the invention of what is now called the
World Championship title there was no
such thing back then efore a five-night
of 396 93 G 64 and as usual we can kind
of forget about the opening I mean it's
kind of like whatever nobody will really
play like this anymore at least in the
top grandmasters but it's still like
perfectly fine to play both sides seem
to be developing relatively normally and
we're going to skip a little bit ahead
d6 Queen d2
Bishan DISA a 97 Bishop h6 and Blackburn
was the person that was always
considering attacking you know he wasn't
much for waiting around moving his
pieces he was not very good at that he
just wanted to go for the throat so he
puts the bishop on h6 tries to destroy
that Bishop on g7 pushes forward on the
King side 95 takes takes Bishop b2 f6
boom
f4 this is black where Blackmer is
coming for you 907 rogue d1 c6 Steinitz
tries to play position on East Agnes was
a player that you know he didn't mind
defending and he had a relatively good
scoring as people that attacked because
Tiny's understood the positional value
of defending however we're talking about
the late 1800s back then defense is very
different to what we know right now
computer has helped us figure out how to
defend enormous Lee from the ages of
towel and Korchnoi and bad Vinick to the
edge of now because para Carlsen Anand
you know the attacks are completely
different because we figured out ways of
defending structures ways of defending
the King seeing things that seemed
impossible to play are now possible we
didn't or they didn't know back then
what was possible was impossible what
was bad and what was good what
structures were hold the bow and which
ones weren't they were just guessing
they made it up on the fly for me this
is obvious because I've studied the
grades because I started the past but
they didn't know they were just making
things up so for me I see this and I see
the blacks position is bad but it's not
so obvious how you break through so
Bishop c4 Bishop d7 takes takes f5 and
Blackburn came up with this amazing
concept he goes f5 which looks kind of
silly because it does give up the v
square but on the other hand allows me
to take on g6 and maybe play recap 6
that doesn't sound a blackboard 98 and
the unbelievable sacrifice ePHI a move
that looks like it simply cannot be
played there's two pawns defending that
square how can you just put one there
you're not even defending this pawn with
anything but it's blackboard he uses the
initiative now it's very obvious that
you cannot take the pawn the D pawn
because 96 check and this Queen bye-bye
there's a pin on the bishop and a double
attack for the night on Queen therefore
you have to take with the pawn but this
was blackboards point even then after 96
check Bishop takes pawn takes the idea
was simply to open up the F file so that
I Mike pieces go through and it actually
was funny I was looking at this left
game with the computer earlier and it
actually it took it a while to find d5
and then like I put it in any five and
it's like oh yeah that's a pretty good
move I'm like wow you know this was play
like hundred and some years ago so of
course at what I was telling you guys
about is that the offense does seem
increased amazingly if you gave this to
a grandmaster nowadays I would probably
survive with minimal losses maybe I
would have a bad position at the end but
people were not used to defending back
then it was very difficult to defend
positions they didn't know the
techniques they didn't know how to play
passive they didn't know how much you
could hold on to a position before it
collapsed so in this position
Ruki 7 was played which is probably not
best rook if I was probably little more
excited riki 7 Queen g5 and then
Blackburn boom just coming Queenie aid
was played to unpin the rook and
probably this is actually the big
mistake of the game it was imperative to
put the night on b6 which looks like a
silly move because it unde offends the
pawn on d6 and the ricany 7 but these
pieces would like the knight back on c8
but there's nothing immediate and it's
important to try to bring the rook on a8
back into the game
so at the moment unfortunately Queenie
Aid was played and now well fortunately
for chess history I think Luke d3 all
the rooks are coming
notice how passive black is on the Queen
side he hasn't been able to develop and
blackburn beautifully exploits this rook
takes c6 rook h3 boom queen h6 on the
mix queen e7 check King g8 and the great
William Stein it fell to the move and
this is why it was important to move the
knight out Rilke fate
Queen takes fourth Queen takes h7
checkmate
they play quite a few I'm afraid I don't
have the number for you but they played
many signings did have the upper upper
half upper hand against blackboard as
did most of the people that I mentioned
one of the zuker towards most famous
game was actually a win against
Blackburn so it's true that you know he
did get his victories once in a while
but he was definitely overshadowed by
the better players
there is no doubt that steinitz was a
more a player with more fundamentals and
it was he was definitely stronger but
once in a while you know you were not
crazy tactician like Blackburn could get
a game like this off yeah so this game
was actually kind of like the Blackburn
style
he was always worse worse worse worse
and then he would find something that I
got of nowhere and win and you always
had to be very carefully but with
Blackburn because he was known to be a
very resourceful player
unlike Steinitz Steinitz was the player
that built up his game he had
fundamentals you know he would go to the
center defend his pieces activate this
go for the initiative step by step by
step very systematic very you know like
the way we play chess now the way we
tell you guys you know go floor is the
center develop your pieces don't need
your King week you know black we didn't
care so he we're gonna see a game that
he played against Swartz and now it was
famous that steinitz didn't like black
form Steinitz and black were never got
along
Blackburn was a very big tall burly guy
he liked whisky more than he should and
he was it was very violent he was a very
sore loser
and this was back when you could drink
during tournaments you know this is back
when the time control was for example
two hours for 30 moves two hours for
dinner one hour for 15 moves then
adjournment and then we continue the
next day so you can imagine how many
drinks you can have in that span of time
so this is his game against Jack
Schwartz Schwartz one of the stronger
players of his era even though he never
made the headlines you know it's one of
those players that unless he were kind
of a chess aficionado you've never
really heard of but he was actually very
strong for his time so we're gonna just
not care about the opening because it's
pretty whatever actually this knight on
c3 is really badly placed in this
structure because as you can see it
doesn't have anywhere to go
it would rather go to d2 so he can go to
g3 but whatever if he fixes it a little
bit artificially but this also means
that you had to commit the night before
any other moves just little details
Queen c7 Bishop III and now Blackburn
oh yeah the reason I mentioned Stein it
is because tiniest thought this game was
just absolutely beautiful now this is
part of Blackburn's magic this is kind
of like this doesn't really work and
Kasparov would crush your ten out of ten
but back in 1990 you know you could get
away with this stuff Knight takes g3
yeah yeah been in the st. Louis Chess
Club real 9:33 fun 63 Bishop takes c3
and now this looks like a blunder it
looks like after pawn thinks you're just
gonna have to agree to a draw or you
know maybe you're gonna get checkmated
this doesn't look good for white you
know at best scenario draw you take on
g3 Queen takes g3 check King h1 draw
right now
huh well the route could move up but the
bishop is still defending age six so
that doesn't seem any fatal flaw with
this at the moment but it just seems
like a draw what Blackburn had actually
sacrificed this fun which is like a kind
of funny really funny this won't work
that doesn't work but it's like his idea
he goes kingi to Bam Bam he sacrificed
the font to get it out of the way for
his rooks he's bringing his rooks into
the attack / quechuan been hitting h7 9
f8 rook h3 doubling up on the H file why
not
g6 ruqayya tron rook the 8th Bishop g5
rook d7 c4 to soften up black on the
diagonals pawn takes Bishop takes he
shouldn't but okay it's 1881 thanks and
thanks and c4 h5 wreckage for b5 Bishop
b3 alright
black could have played better I agree
everybody agrees but if they played
better we wouldn't like care because so
after 96 here blackburn puts in a
devilish trap he goes Bishop f6 and
Schwarz boom
Falls for it hard hard hard he goes
Knight f4 Chuck attacking the King which
is a little unfortunate for white and
taking on it and defending h5 and also
defending g6 in public
so if route King F 1 you know I can just
play whatever but here Blackman played
Queen takes f4 Bishop takes up 4 rook
takes h5 and as many pieces of black
house it is impossible to after pawn
takes rook takes stop checkmate on the
square h8 this is black bird that's what
he did you know he didn't care he just
checked meat in here so this is actually
a pretty famous game this was and I'm
gonna read a couple of the notes because
this is one of the few games that we
have saved that was bear bear very
annotated by Blackburn Blackburn
published a book late in his career that
is quite famous actually as Blackmore
blackbirds memoirs on his game but none
of them are very well annotated this is
one of the most personal ones that he
has so where is he d4 d5 see for he's
playing Samwell Lib shoots which was a
strong player back then this is the
tournament in the international chess
congress in New York which is a
tournament that run for many many years
he's 693 96 and ever okay we're not
gonna care because the opening this is
1889 believe it or not opening theory
didn't develop that much since 1881 and
it says a good move it opens up the game
and the night cannot be taking with
impunity nowadays we know this is a
terrible move because the nine doesn't
actually want to go to you for but
that's one hundred and some years later
c5 Queen e2 f5 and he says this greats a
weakness on e6 probably Knight df6 was
better he's right there I want ride once
in a while
broke the f1c four takes takes 95 9 f 6
and this is where Blackburn place like
Blackburn because he's black bird what
else is he gonna do
g4 all right I don't know about that
Queenie a queen f1 Bishop d6 h3 and
we're gonna skip ahead a little bit and
before even though at no point did I
actually say that why did something
horrible to his position this is
evaluation by blackboard whites only
chance it's an attack on the Kings side
to prevent the advance of blacks danger
response in the Queen side nowadays we
know those pawns are not going anywhere
they're just kind of a it's just kind of
stuck we're not actually queening but
you know Blackburn whatever 97 takes
takes 92 Bishop f4 Knight f4 root D f7
g5 all right rook air-five
and he says to be able to play h6 on the
advance of whites Knight pawn he
actually said to advance
pawn to King rook three in order to meet
pawn king night six yes even for me
descriptive notation is very difficult
king each one a five
rook g1 why is his why is he putting
pieces on the King side because that's
what he knows how to do worship CA Queen
g3 the beginning of a combination
tempting black to attack the weak points
in the Queen side Queen a4 and he yields
to temptation nowadays we know that
Queen a for judgments a bunch of pawns
be three eggs takes takes rooks e7 a
rook established on the seventh rank is
often as good as a passed pawn a little
I don't know about that and the rest is
lovely
a4 unconscious of their doom the little
victims play at this stage did German
accord and back then what a German meant
is that you seal a move
and what happens after that is that the
arbiter comes and takes the sealed move
and both sides go home to analyze now
Blackburn was known to be particularly
bad after a Germans because unlike his
opponents who spent all night analyzing
he spent all night analyzing at the bar
and somehow his analysis the next day
did not quite match up to his opponents
and here it says at this stage dear
German occurred and white was called on
to make his sealed move so it's white to
move he doesn't make it on the board he
writes it down puts it on an envelope
before play was resumed Lipschutz was
asked how his game stood he has a little
bit of an attack he answered but my two
passports must win a view that was
endorsed by Stein it's
on opening the envelope and finding my
move g6 he still thought himself safe
but the next move rook takes g7 check
and we'll take a look a look at that
came upon him like a thunderbolt and
caused the greatest excitement among
spectators of whom Steinitz was one he
bent his head over the board and would
scarcely believe that a meeting position
had been created g6 h6 rook takes g7 if
King h8 of course I mean you're just
losing so you have to take 9 h5 check
sacrificing another piece simply with
the point that after rook h5 Queen c7
check all you need is this Queen because
surprisingly after the move Queen f6
there is no good way of defending
against Queen d6 check if the bishop
interposes Queen takes f8 King g5 what
else
Queen f king g5 rook e1 so this is made
after Bishop f7 takes if king g7
Queeny seven you cannot interpose
because I just take it so you have to go
back and Queen age seven checkmate
a beautiful domination by the Queen here
on c7 and the pawn nothing else needed
an absolutely brilliant checkmate
now that showed him now Blackbird didn't
just beat you know Lipschitz and
Schwartz he also beat last year a couple
of times while Alaska was reigning world
champion and we have to remember that
Blackburn he died at the age of 82 in
1924 and this games I'm showing you are
in the late 1890s so he was not exactly
a kid he was but he was playing with the
best we're gonna go just through not
through the game but at some point we're
gonna show more or less how Blackburn
place so we have this position in which
black sports position is terrible he's
white roll up all the black ferns
positions are terrible he asked the
white has a passport on b5 there's no
attack on the kingside this is the
backward spawn for no reason he hasn't
even cancelled this night on b7 is
terrible
everything is terrible so why does
Blackburn attack do he attacks on the
kingside what else he gonna do
rook c8 or hook c1 95 92 boom h4 92 and
this is this is Blackburn g5 so takes up
four takes every pawn route g8 boom boom
Bishop g3 still up up on Bishop e6
rookie 194 just bringing everything in
here Knight f1 Bishop g5 more fuel into
the fire
rugby one into the open file this is
Alaska we're talking about 93 it should
before
95 Queen g5 everything else in there f3
and a beautiful combination rook h1
check after Bishop after king takes
Bishop takes g3 has a devastating double
attack Queen h6 Queen h2 is a sorry
Queen h6 Bishop f2 is checkmate right
the knight guards h2 but nobody's
guarding f2 the other one is that after
1963 because I sacrificed my rook and I
destroyed the defender on g3 I have 9f2
Chuck
and after King Jiwon 91 night of 5 takes
takes here to your tier blacks up of
Queen and won without any problems
against Alaska yes
he actually manhandle a scare more than
once this is another this is very pretty
this is again last year against who's
calling me
Lasker against Joseph Henry Blackburn
and here last year place to move rookie
to simply defending the pawn on f2 black
from West like no no no no check here
takes on h2 I'm the only thou did Alaska
realize you cannot take on h2 because of
Queen h5 check taking your rook
black went on to win without too many
problems even him did I need more than
that of course he tried to kill him when
the kingside but that was good enough so
um this doesn't matter so yeah this is
more blackburn he's playing some guy he
was actually very famous for his
simultaneous exhibitions he was really
really good at them he would drink
whiskey and he would like play his
simultaneous exhibition and he he
created the concept of an poisson during
a simultaneous he was giving the
simultaneous exhibition and some guy in
front of him was you know drinking his
whiskey and he put it here and he was
like and passant took his whiskey drank
it kept on playing there's a whiskey and
passant he just grabbed the whiskey so
here he's playing against some badly
Guyana and after this moves played g5
because because he can and after Bishop
g5 rookie a rookie king h 1 h 6 bishop
h4 he went boom bishop h 3g h 3 Queen d7
does this work not work just my king age
2 and everything's defended but this guy
was so clever at putting up traps
there's two ways of defending this king
h2 and 91 but 91 actually fails rook
takes g1 King takes Queen takes h3 and
now surprisingly what's actually lost
if you go Bishop takes have six the
simple King d7 with the threat of rube
g8 Chuck followed by mate
you cannot play Bishop g3 because it's
simply pinned 92 was played Knight g4
threatening Queen h2 checkmate Knight f3
King demon bringing in the last guy to
the attack d4 route g8 Bishop g3 and the
killer 93 threatening checkmate on g2
forcing the move pawn takes c3 Queen
takes g3 check
more Blackburn in the same style I
remember which on this one oh yeah
little combinations like this is what
made him famous this is a same
simultaneous exhibition in Hastings he's
playing and then so we don't know who he
was playing unfortunately a lot of the
records of the simultaneous exhibitions
have been lost he would he is rumored to
have played over a hundred thousand
chess games in his career based off his
high molt Aeneas you know this is before
like ICC one minute wasn't was he lived
in 82 years so he played a hundred
thousand games at least that's the rumor
unfortunately we don't have the record
of most limited we've lost tragically a
lot of the names of the his opponents
and a lot of the records of his games
but this one is famous facie page 7
check King takes check King g8 and now
unfortunately here Queen h5 doesn't
quite work because after Bishop takes g5
it seems like I don't have quite
checkmate anywhere and if I go to g6
first then again Bishop here Queen here
Bishop h6 seems to cover just in time
so instead Rock H a check takes check
here g6 with the unstoppable rook
air-five check your checkmate more black
bird which one is this one oh yeah yeah
this one's pretty also a simultaneous
exhibition Evans gambit because you know
she's black word style d4 takes doesn't
care about the pawns Queen b3 takes this
guy Bishop e3 and now this little
combination this is actually all very
precise which is pretty surprising after
this I'll move all moves our best 96
check takes takes so the nine moves
Knight a5 rook e1 check takes takes down
a rook typical romantic style cannot
play to d8 because I forgot why but you
can't I think just like 95 or something
you just can't so you guys King f8 and
then BOOM
can't take because d7 and because there
is no good way of stopping Queen c7
Queen d8 Chuck made there is none there
is no good way of doing it
black resigned the threat is here Queen
c7 and then Queen d8
there is nothing to do about it black
resigned in this position more blackburn
which one is this one
ah this one is really pretty this is
like clever this is actually not a
simultaneous exhibition he was playing
the British championship in 1868 it was
the champion of Great Britain more than
a few times
and he's white he's black against down
Harper
whoever that is aged six takes takes
ship h3 here and now you know most
people would just play Bishop e7 and
develop but he wants to bring in the
Queen
so f4 Queen h4 Queen III now very
typical black for g5 because favorite
move queen g3 route g8 and man was this
guy devilish this is one of my favorite
traps of him rook g8 now if you take on
h4
I simply take back and well you lose
right so you cannot actually take my
queen
however it seems like Bishop f1 freeze
wide from the problems if I take on f1 I
can even first take and after the trade
I simply take your bishop and it seems
like you're okay
like you've developed well your
construction looks alright but this guy
goes pawn takes f4 you cannot take the
Queen of the bishop because of the pin
but the rook just hanging nobody's
defending this Queen takes GA was played
on Knight f6 and suddenly there is not a
single square on the G file for this
Queen
and it's just the material that he has
on the kingside is just enough to
checkmate his opponent Queen h8 queen g4
Chuck King h1 f3 threatening Bishop g2
Chuck King g1 Bishop takes f1 check King
takes up one Queen G to checkmate
only way of defending is to swap that
vision Queen takes rook g1 defending
from the mate and just enough material
Knight g4 threatening checkmate on h2
also threatening checkmate on f2 so for
example if I define by playing here
checkmate therefore rook takes G 4 was
forced Queen takes g4 and nobody can
defend now the crazy thing about this
guys that some of the stuff actually
works actually G takes f 4 wins by force
the rook sacrifice is completely sound
crazy
so Queen takes Knight f6 it's pretty
very pretty
let's see we got something else from him
or that I ran out of stuff hopefully not
this was just very typical Blackburn
King f8 was played I don't remember why
cuz 96 was a thread or something and
then check 97 Queen takes a 7
cannot take because rook the ATIS
checkmate strange background now notice
that he could have played queen a7
immediately but first he lose this
Knight 27 so that the King doesn't have
this square and then after Queen takes a
7 the combination works how he played it
immediately of course it doesn't work
because of King e7 it was very pretty so
here we have this position in which
black furnace obviously crushing because
he's up a pawn and he has like
everything in the position but the way
he finishes it's always like very
glamorous this is just blackbird this
simultaneous exhibition in 1875 95
attacking the Queen Queen e6 and now the
normal way of playing is just e7 check
on Bishop e3 but he sacrifices his Queen
because he can cannot take on B 3
because d7 is checkmate with a pawn so
Knight f6 is played d6 check sorry this
time attract Knight takes rook takes the
Queen still hanging still untaken ville
because after Queen takes rook e7 King
f8 97 she initiate checkmate
so Queen e5 was played and then the more
prosaic now black is just completely
crushed and he lost horribly after this
nice little finishing combination rook
takes here and check the idea being that
if you play King D 7 this is checkmate
that's why you sacrifice the rook and
anything else is just as bad
so this was the great Henry Blackburn he
was known for his sacrifices and all his
crazy little combinations not
necessarily that they all work but we're
kind of glad that we had him he was one
of the players that even though his
style was probably incorrect it was
always fun and he was one of the few
people that play this incorrect romantic
style and could still play against the
best he could still beat Lasky he could
still beat Stein as he could still be a
suger torte you know he could still beat
all of them she got him because he
envied never he did win over many many
times simply because he had like this
crazy mind you know this ability to
calculate this ability to come up with
resources out of nothing so despite the
fact that he wasn't exactly the founding
father of positional chess and where we
don't remember him for anything that's
not dubious he was the black play he was
the player that could beat anybody at
any moment and that is the first
greatest British chess player Joseph
Henry